eighteen year Major League Baseball
veteran dan please act back here on the
show how are you Dan rich I'm doing good
you're suiting this brawl every other
day I thought you cuz I taught you what
okay I think Rick's gonna be a call it
okay good well I'm glad you think of me
because you knew I'd have a problem with
it or because you know what the last
time we had the discussion with the Red
Sox and Oreos thing with the Manny
Machado and should they have hit em
should they have not a venom so that's
the first thing that came to my mind
well I mean you are in in a way let's
just put it this way even though I think
it's your second or third appearance on
this show you are now our de facto go-to
unwritten rule guy guy comes to this
sort of thing let's start with this
thing is did that break a written rule
or an unwritten rule that Strickland
went ahead and hit Harper for what
appears to be two playoff home runs from
years past you know what I I have never
been I'm as old school as it gets but I
have never been one that that at all
things that what Strickland did was good
I I could I have never understood why a
pitcher would throw a ball and
deliberately hit a guy because one he's
either he's he's hot against the guy or
he can't get the guy out to me that's a
lame excuse if there was ever rich an
occasion that it was it couldn't have
looked more deliberate than that pitch
was okay and this wasn't about the
Giants this wasn't about the Nationals
this was about one guy this was about
hunter Strickland getting back for 2014
two home runs
that Bryce Harper hit when he was a 21
year old the second one was he animated
when he went to dugout of course he was
but rich this wasn't a game in May this
wasn't a game a second game of a
doubleheader in August this was playoff
baseball in 2014 tensions are at high
testosterone is raging you're playing to
get to the World Series and and I have
put this and I don't know if you this
I'm just going to tell you the way I saw
it sure I applauded what Bryce Harper
did for this reason I played for 18
seasons and I said in many a dugouts on
six different teams from Milwaukee to
Chicago Toronto the Diamondbacks the
Pirates
where a guy felt like on the team I was
playing with that he got he was thrown
at intentionally would come in and say
somebody's got to go down this has got
to stop or if a guy thought he got hit
on purpose my feeling was always this
rich if I was standing there in a
batter's box and I felt like Rich Eisen
deliberately threw a pitch to hit me and
did I could do one of two things I could
either go to first base or I could say
the guys out there 60 feet six inches
away and go get him and I applaud what
Bryce Harper did because a lot of guys
will talk like oh man hey we got to do
something up come in a dugout go scream
up the runway and for three or four days
they're all complaining the pictures
somebody's got to go down somebody's got
to get hit you know and and as a picture
sometimes you sit there go late if you
really think he hit you then go to guys
right out there he's 60 feet away go out
there and get him
and I applauded I applauded what he did
because if there was ever this was so
blatantly obvious rich that I think when
you look at the way the league came down
that find hunters they suspended him for
six games and only four games for rice
Harbor this was as blatant this had
nothing to do with a hard slide like
Manny Machado going into Pedroia this
had nothing to do with you know a guy
did this was strictly a personal thing
between Strickland to Bryce Harper sense
all that was what happens tonight then I
mean we get whacked you don't think
anything happens tonight Buster Posey
doesn't get one in a year or something
stupid thrown behind him no no not at
all I this this to me rich when these
things escalate and they keep going is
when it's be it you have a problem with
a certain team like you feel like
there's a dirty slide or they're
stealing whatever crazy list the
baseball players aren't the smartest
guys in the world rich let's face it you
know what I mean sure for whatever
reason teams hold grudges players hold
grudges I didn't like what happened
between the Red Sox and the Orioles
because they had it they had a chance to
hit Manny Machado and they missed him
they kept throwing at him till
eventually they were going to hit him
right this to me this has
thing to do with with either of these
two teams this was Hunter Strickland and
I don't even think this was Bryce Harper
but Bryce Harper realized wait a minute
he just threw it at me and hit me on
purpose
with that said I can guarantee you this
rich I've watched this over and over and
over for 48 hours if Buster Posey had to
do it all over again he wouldn't have
stood there like he did I written I
don't know what's right and I don't know
what's wrong but I can tell you this
after playing for 18 years and I got a
text matches from a guy that caught me
and was a member of the braceland they
won the World Series Charlie O'Brien
he's another guy as old-school as
old-school gets sent me a text message
yesterday saying I can't believe Buster
stood there one of the unwritten or I
guess you're gonna call it an unwritten
rule for a catcher is you don't let a
guy get out there to the mound you do
whether you have to get in front of the
guy whether you have to tackle them
whether you this thing all could have
been I'm not saying it should have been
stopped but if Buster Posey would have
immediately jumped out there and grabbed
Bryce Harper so between him I don't
think this would have escalated to the
way it did Dan plans my personal opinion
dan please second of MLB networks and
what do you think was going through
Posey's mind just like he couldn't
believe Strickland did it or he thought
it was a dumbass move and I'm not going
to support it but yeah yeah I'm going to
ask me part of it is that and part of
his a guy that's already had some you
know some injury right he's had some
concussion issues himself he's had a
knee with the Posey you know all the
collisions at home plate that was
another reason and I think he just he
vapor walked for a few seconds and was
like what the hell's going on here and
before I can guarantee you this rich I I
would almost guarantee you that a Buster
Posey had to do it all over again he
would have attacked that thing
differently than he did now I know you
you were you were on hold I guess
towards the end of the last segments you
heard what I said that baseball could
stop this by right telling everybody
don't leave the dugout you do you're
subject to suspension and if you leave
your position you're subject to
suspension you've been a reliever what
what does a reliever think as he's
running 300 feet into this frame and you
think I can't wait to beat somebody up
or like what am i doing
I'll tell you what's crazy now going
back to when I came when I first broke
in with the Brewers from Planet County
Stadium right that bullpen was out in
right-center field and you don't have
time to run down those steps and guys
you jumped over the wall right I know
where guys would fall down with twist
and roll and ankle
this is a protocol rich yes when
something like that happens you got to
go you've got to beat those other guys
from the bullpen onto the field nine out
of ten times it's nothing but a lot of
screaming and yelling and pushing and
shoving but you'll have a few ugly
incidents where it gets really ugly and
that could have gotten really really
ugly the other day in San Fran it didn't
and I think fortunately you know the
crazy part about this whole thing rich
is thank goodness that Samar's and Mike
Morris ran into each other because the
market was going up there he was going
out there to get Bryce Harper and I
think that would have turned into a real
melee because Samardzija was going to go
after Bryce Harper and I'm telling you
that thing could have gotten real ugly
so fortunately these two guys ran into
each other and unfortunately for Mike
Morris he's on the 7 day deal because of
a concussion out of it which is crazy so
what would players what would players
say Dan if baseball did step in and
suddenly say you are not allowed to join
a fight let the pitcher and if the
pitcher in the planning and the base
amia and the batter want to go at it
just like hockey let them go at it and
then the umpires come in and break it up
just like just like hockey and I know
baseball doesn't want to be equated
hockey but if you're going to allow
fighting and kids can see this sort of
thing what would players say if there
was a rule instituted like that day you
know what I really think that most
players would probably be in support of
that thing right because I think as a
pitcher if I'm going to deliberately go
out there and hit somebody and if I know
they're going to let Darryl Strawberry
they're going to let Mike Trout they're
going to let Elbert Tools they're going
to let them come out and get them maybe
you would think twice about
intentionally hitting a guy or not right
and the same thing on the flip side as a
hitter if you think that Randy Johnson
or Roger Clemens or Pedro Martinez is
hitting you on purpose boom you go out
there and go ahead and get him you might
you might be onto something you really
might be onto something we'll run that
up the MLB Network slob going to do that
Goforth dan before I let you go tomorrow
my first scheduled guest is Bob Uecker I
couldn't be more excited you got a good
story what's your best Bob Uecker story
from your Mojave there Dan there so that
I know there are he was you know rich
this was at the time like my rookie year
in 86 that was at the height of the
Light beer commercials you know the
front row I mean this was the mr.
Belvedere days yes there were so many I
can't tell you any on the air because
some of them were vulgar is that right
buddy oh rich he's one of the funniest
guys you'll ever meet and I'm telling
you he's got a million stories and the
one thing that I think surprised me the
most because coming up my rookie year
like you know Bob Uecker was he was like
what Harry Caray was - the what - the
Cubs right I mean larger bigger than a
team you kurwa said we would get off the
team bus in Yankee Stadium and we had
some really good players from Wilder
yout Cecil Cooper been totally right and
there's all those people waiting by the
press box where the Bucks would enter
for a game and we'd walk off that bus
and you'd hear a few guys hey Robin you
know hey Cecil when you Kerr walked off
that bus everybody was screaming you you
know front row he was bigger than the
Brewers if you can believe that he was
that big yeah
and he's one of the few people you know
you could you could talk to about movies
and Johnny Carson he appeared on The
Tonight Show forever because Carson
loved having conversations with with Bob
and and I'm looking forward to tomorrow
so uh and on top of it you'll be
surprised how much of a really true
baseball fan this Guy'd loves
broadcasting Brewer baseball games it's
amazing yeah and he's broadcasting a
first-place team like I don't know for
how much longer
everybody's waiting for that other shoe
to drop on it on Milwaukee with the Cubs
to start you know putting the pedal to
the metal but thanks for joining Dan
appreciate it anytime we'll do it again
you got it sir Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy